I'm going to start this lesson by noting that tessellate is the most misspelled
word in computer graphics. So give it a good look and think of doubling every
letter that you can when you spell it. Yes, 2 Ls looks weird to me too, but
that's how it works, and I force myself to spell it correctly. The word,
tessellate is from the Greek word Tessella, which means a small stone in a
mosaic. In English, breaking an object into polygons of any sort is called
tessellation. In computer graphics, a curved surface is often represented by
triangles by placing points on surface and connecting these together. For
example, a geodesic dome is 1 tessellation of a sphere, such as the biosphere in
Montral. When it comes to making surfaces the GPU understands only triangles. To
draw any polygon, we break that polygon into a set of triangles. This process is
naturally called triangulation, usually we use the existing vertices as the
polygon when performing triangulation. The major rule is that when we add an
edge, it has to be entirely inside the polygon. Triangulation is a particular
form of tessellation. Here's the same pentagon tessellated in a fairly arbitrary
way, with new vertices added inside the pentagon and connected together. Once
upon a time some older graphics hardware from the 1980's supported objects such
as polygons or even more complex objects. For example Nvidia's first chip, the
nv1 supported ellipsoids as a basic primitive. Graphics hardware manufacturers
quickly came to realize that the triangle is a fine building block for almost
everything we want to draw. For example one problem with a quadrilateral is that
the surface is poorly defined if all four points are not in the same plane. A
triangle's three points are by definition always in the same plane and, so, have
no such problems. By the way the graphics coprocessor I used to develop on in
the late 1980's cost about $35,000 at the time. It was perhaps at best 1-1
millionth as fast as the fastest GPU's are nowadays, at only at the price of a
BMW.